hi I'm a global shaper philosophies and
I'm the founder of my name you guys had
a meet which is a school seeks to
provide underprivileged children access
to international quality education far
with other in my private schools in the
country I'd like to address the question
I'd care about and how can you continue
to and obviously I care about education
I strongly believe it's only through
education potential be here very
innovative models not only in terms of
improving access but in making wanted
education more relevant to the needs of
today how I plan to continue to
contribute to the world well I hope that
by being here I would be able to pick up
different strategies and different ways
so I could improve the sustainability of
my project and hopefully be able to
replicate it not only as a country not
only in other parts of my country but in
other countries